I am your
father this Revelation from The Empire
Strikes Back is often considered one of
the most shocking moments in movie
history even most of the cast and crew
were kept in the dark as Mark Hill
explained on The Graham Norton Show in
2017 the version they filmed had an
alternate twist in that scene the way we
filmed it Vader said you don't know the
truth Obi One killed your father after
filming the scene Hamill said that the
director Irvin kersner f him aside and
told him that Darth Vader is actually
Luke's father however he was forbidden
to tell anyone else including his
castmates that meant that even Harrison
Ford and Carrie fiser didn't learn the
real line until they finally saw a
screening of the film at the screening
when that happened Harrison turned to me
and said hey kid you didn't tell me that